The two models persisted for at least 50 years,
in part because it was really hard to test which of the two models was correct.
So when you think about it,
what you're trying to ask is what caused a new trait to appear?
Did the environment cause the trait to appear?
Or did the trait appear first and the environment simply selected upon the trait?
So you can think in your lifetime,
you know,
most of the traits we see out there are preexisting,
and so you needed a situation where you had a population of
individuals where the trait didn't exist.
So that was the number one challenge.
For example,
let's say we're looking for a trait for humans to have purple hair, and
nobody has purple hair.
So,
that's what you start with.
And then you can say,
okay,
now I'm going to see, when did the purple hair appear?
I'm going to actually visualize the appearance of the purple hair.
And then,
if I visualize it,
I can ask well did it happen before or after something that would make purple hair be
advantageous.
So in that model we have three components.
We first have to have a population which didn't have purple hair to start with, the appearance of purple hair has to be
frequent enough that it happens in our lifetime, so we have to be able to observe it
experimentally,
and third,
we have to be able to show whether that trait happened before or after the
environmental change happened.
So did it happen in the absence of any environmental change?
Or did it happen as a response to environmental change?
So we're stuck with this conundrum of
first observing something new that nobody's ever seen before,
having it happen in a timely fashion that we can observe it happen, and third,
being able to determine when it happened relative to any potential environmental change.
So those were the conundrums, the problem that faced them, and there were a lot of crazy
experiments done.
Lamarckians did things like,
you know,
chopping off the tails of mice and then seeing if the baby mice had shorter tails
and, you know, the answer was they didn't.
But then you could argue, well,
they really just didn't do enough mice to be able to see the rare mice that could've responded to the environmental
change.
And so they-- and it wasn't really an appearance of a new trait.
Then there are other examples of where a new trait appears,
like a human breaks its arm,
but that's not really a heritable trait,
it's just something that caused damage to the organism.
It's new,
but it's not really something that changes its genetic material in response to some, you know.
So, those were the problems that faced and
nobody could really find a system that could bring all those characteristics together.